how's it going everybody welcome back to
the channel I'm sure a lot of you have
heard about the news about Jeremy Renner
being hospitalized after a traumatic
injury he suffered well today we have an
official update and a statement that his
family has released to the public and it
is very traumatic news but it is also at
the same time very good news for Jeremy
Renner now if you're not aware two days
ago Jeremy Renner of course the actor
who plays Hawkeye was in Reno Nevada and
on New Year's Day he suffered a very
traumatic injury many injuries actually
due to a snow plowing incident the
police got there and they rushed him to
the hospital immediately and he has had
two surgeries now now they haven't
released a statement about what
specifically happened in the incident
but we do know that he suffered blunt
chest trauma and Orthopedic injuries and
the last that we heard was he was in
critical but stable condition Jeremy
Renner underwent two surgeries but is
now apparently doing okay and his family
like I said has released a statement to
the public and it reads Jeremy's family
would like to express their gratitude to
the the incredible doctors and nurses
looking after him Truckee Meadows fire
and rescue washu County Sheriff Reno
city mayor Hillary shive and the Carano
and Murdoch families they are also
tremendously overwhelmed and
appreciative of the outpouring of love
and support from his fans so the good
news is is that it really seems like
Jeremy is going to be okay when the news
first broke out all we knew was that he
was in very critical condition he
suffered a very traumatic injury and he
was rushed to the hospital so of course
people were thinking the worst and the
crazy thing is the worst could have
happened we could have lost Jeremy but
thanks to these tremendous doctors and
all of the people that helped him he
made it out of the surgeries okay and it
looks like he is in stable condition now
according to the reports and he's going
to be okay so keep him in your thoughts
keep him in your prayers and if we hear
anything else about the situation we'll
be sure to do an update our Hawkeye is
strong I'm sure he's going to be okay
but leave some positive comments for
Jimmy Renner in the comments down below
we'll catch you all in the next video
woof woof
foreign